that mr president
mr secretary general
my fellow delegates
to all those who dedicate themselves to
this noble mission of this institution
it's my honor to speak to you for the
first time as president of the united
states
we meet this year in a moment of
intermingled with great pain
and extraordinary possibility
we've lost so much to this deputy this
devastating pandemic
that continues to claim lives around the
world
and impact so much on our existence
we're mourning more than 4.5
million people
people of every nation
from every background
each death
is an individual
heartbreak
but
our shared grief is a poignant reminder
that our collective future will hinge on
our ability to recognize our common
humanity
and to act together
ladies and gentlemen
this is the clear and urgent choice that
we face here
at the dawning of what must be a
decisive decade for our world
a decade they will quite literally
determine our futures
as a global community
we're challenged by urgent and looming
crises
wherein lie enormous opportunities if if
we can summon the will
and resolve to seize these opportunities
will we work together to save lives
defeat covet 19
everywhere
and take the necessary steps to prepare
ourselves for the next pandemic
for there will be another one
or will we fail to harness the tools at
our disposal
as the more virulent and dangerous
variants take hold
when we meet the threat of challenging
climate the challenging climate we're
all feeling already ravaging every part
of our world
with extreme weather
or
will we suffer the merciless march of
ever worsening droughts and floods
more intense fires and hurricanes
longer heat waves
and rising seas
will we affirm
and uphold the human dignity and human
rights
under which
nations and common cause
more than seven decades ago formed this
institution
will we apply
and strengthen the core tenants of
internet of the international system
including the u.n charter and the
universal declaration of human rights
as we seek to shape
the emergence of new
technologies and deter
new threats
or
will we allow these universal those
universal principles
to be trampled and twisted in the
pursuit of naked political power
in my view how we answer these questions
in this moment
whether we choose to fight for our
shared future or not will reverberate
for generations yet to come
simply put
we stand in my view at an inflection
point in history
and i'm here today
to share with you
how the united states intends to work
with partners and allies to answer these
questions
and the commitment
of my new administration helped lead the
world toward a more peaceful
prosperous future
for all people
instead of continuing to fight the wars
of the past
we are fixing our eyes
on devoting our resources to the
challenges
that hold the keys to our collective
future
ending this pandemic
addressing the climate crisis
managing the shifts in global power
dynamics
shaping the rules of the world on vital
issues like trade
cyber and emerging technologies
and facing the threat of terrorism
as it stands today
we've ended
20 years of conflict in afghanistan
and as we close this period of
relentless war
we're opening a new era of relentless
diplomacy
of using the power
of our development aid
to invest in new ways of lifting people
up
around the world
of renewing and defending democracy
of proving that no matter how
challenging
or how complex the problems we're going
to face
government by and for the people
is still the best way to deliver for all
of our people
and as the united states turns our focus
to the priorities and the regions of the
world like the indo-pacific that are
most consequential today and tomorrow
we'll do so with our allies and partners
through cooperation of multilateral
institutions like the united nations
to amplify our collective strength and
speed our progress
toward dealing with its global
challenges
is the fundamental truth
of the 21st century
within each of our countries
and as a global community
that our own success
is bound up in others succeeding as well
to deliver for our own people must also
engage deeply
with the rest of the world
to ensure that our own future
we must work together with other
partners
our partners toward a shared future
our security our prosperity
and our very freedoms
are interconnected
in my view as never before
and so
i believe we must work together
as never
before over the last eight months
i prioritized rebuilding our alliances
revitalizing our partnerships
and recognizing they are essential and
central
to america's enduring security and
prosperity
we have reaffirmed our sacred nato
alliance to article five commitment
we're working with our allies toward a
new strategic concept
that will help our alliance better take
on evolving threats of today
and tomorrow
we renewed our engagement with the
european union
a fundamental partner in tackling the
full range of significant issues
facing our world today
we elevated the quad partnership among
australia
india japan and the united states
to take on challenges ranging from
health security
to climate
to emerging technologies
we're engaging with regional
institutions from asean to the african
union to the organization of american
states
to focus on people's urges needs for
better health
and better economic outcomes
we're back at the table
in international forums
especially the united nations
to focus attention
and to spur global action
on shared challenges
we are re-engaged
at the world health organization
and working in close partnership with
kovacs
to deliver life-saving vaccines around
the world
we rejoin the paris climate agreement
and we're running to retake a seat in
the human rights council next year at
the u.n
and as the united states seeks to rally
the world action
we will lead not just with the example
of our power
but god ruling with the power of our
example
make no mistake
the united states will continue to
defend ourselves our allies and our
interests against attack including
terrorist threats
as we prepare to use force if any is
necessary but to defend our vital u.s
national interest including against
ongoing and imminent threats
but the mission must be clear and
achievable
undertaken with informed consent of the
american people
and whenever possible
in partnership
with our allies
you us military power
must be our tool of last resort
not our first
and should not be used as an answer to
every problem we see
around the world
indeed today
many of our greatest concerns cannot be
solved or even addressed
through the force of arms
bombs and bullets cannot defend against
covet 19
or its future variants
to fight this pandemic we need a
collective act of science
and political will
we need to act now
to get shots in arms as fast as possible
and expand access to oxygen
test treatments
to save lives around the world
and for the future we need to create a
new mechanism
to finance global health security
that builds on our existing development
assistance
and global health
and a global health threat council
council
that is armed with the tools we need
to monitor and identify emerging
pandemics
so that we can take immediate action
already the united states has put more
than 15 billion dollars
toward global covert response the global
cobra response
we've shipped more than 160 million
doses
of covert 19 vaccine to other countries
this includes 130 million doses from our
own supply
and the first tranches of the half a
billion doses
of pfizer vaccine we purchased to donate
through kovacs
planes carrying vaccines from the united
states have already landed in 100
countries
bringing people all over the world a
little dose of hope
as one american nurse termed it to me
a dose of hope directing the american
people
and importantly
no strings attached
and tomorrow
at the u.s hosted global 19 covet 19
summit i'll be announcing additional
commitments
as we seek to advance the fight against
cover 19
and hold ourselves accountable around
specific targets
on three key challenges
saving lives now
vaccinating the world
and building back better
this year has also brought widespread
death and devastation
from the borderless climate crisis
the extreme weather events
that we have seen in every part of the
world and you all know it and feel it
represent what the secretary general has
rightly called
code red
for humanity
the scientists and experts are telling
us
that we're fast approaching
a point of no return in a literal sense
to keep within our reach
the vital goal of limiting global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius every
nation
needs to bring their highest possible
ambitions to the table
when we meet in glasgow for cop26
and then
to have to keep raising our collective
ambition
over time
in april
i announced the united states ambitious
new goal under the paris agreement
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions from
the united states
by 50 to 52 percent below
2005 levels by 2030
as we work toward achieving the clean
energy economy
with net zero emissions by 2050
and my administration is working closely
with our congress
to make critical investments in green
infrastructure and electric vehicles
that'll help us lock in progress at home
toward our climate goals
and the best part is
making these ambitious investments isn't
just good climate policy
it's a chance for each of our countries
to invest in ourselves
and our own future
it's an enormous opportunity to create
good paying jobs
for workers in each of our countries
and to spur long-term economic growth
that will improve the quality of life
for all of our people
we also have to support the countries
and people
that will be hit the hardest
and that have the fewest resources to
help them adapt
in april
i announce the united states will double
our public international financing
to help developing nations tackle the
climate crisis and today
i'm proud to announce that we'll work
with the congress to double that number
again
including for adaptation efforts
this will make the united states a
leader in public climate finance and
with our added support together with
increased private capital
and other from other donors
will be able to meet the goal of
mobilizing
100 billion dollars
to support climate action in developing
nations
as we deal with these crises
we're also encountering a new era
an air of new technologies and
possibilities
that have potential to release
and reshape every aspect of human
existence
and it's up to all of us
to determine whether these technologies
are forced to empower people or
to deepen repression
as new technologies continue to evolve
we'll work together with our democratic
partners to ensure
that new advances in areas from
biotechnology to quantum computing
5g artificial intelligence and more
are used to lift people up
to solve problems
and advance human freedom
not
to suppress dissent
or target minority communities
and the united states tends to make a
profound investment
in research and innovation
working with
countries at all stages of economic
development
to develop new tools and technologies
to help us tackle the challenges of this
second quarter
of the 21st century
and beyond
we're hardening our critical
infrastructure against cyber attacks
disrupting ransomware networks
and working to establish clear
rules of the road for all nations
as it relates to cyberspace
we reserve the right to respond
decisively to cyber attacks that
threaten our people our allies our
interest
we will pursue new rules with global
trade and economic growth
to strive to level the playing field so
it's not artificially tipped in favor of
any one country
at the expense of others
and every nation
has a right an opportunity to compete
fairly
we will strive to ensure that basic
labor rights
environmental safeguards
and intellectual property are protected
and that the benefits of globalization
are shared broadly throughout all our
societies
we'll continue to uphold the
long-standing rules and norms that have
formed the guard rails of international
engagement for decades
that have been essential
to the development of nations around the
world
bedrock commitments like freedom of
navigation
adherence to international laws and
treaties
support for arms control measures
that reduce the rest the risk
and enhance transparency
our approach is firmly grounded
and fully consistent with the united
nations mission
and the values we've agreed to
when we drafted this charter
these are commitments we all made
and that we're all bound to
uphold and as we strive to deal with
these urgent challenges whether they're
long-standing or newly emerging
we must also deal with one another
all the major powers of the world
have a duty
in my view to carefully manage their
relationships
so they do not tip
from responsible competition
to conflict
the united states will compete and will
compete vigorously
and lead with our values and our
strength
will stand up for our allies and our
friends and oppose attempts
by stronger countries to dominate weaker
ones
whether through changes to territory by
force
economic coercion
technical exploitation or disinformation
but we're not seeking
say it again we are not seeking a new
cold war
or a world divided
into rigid blocks
the united states is ready to work with
any nation
that steps up
and pursues peaceful resolution
to share challenges
even if we have intense disagreements
in other areas
because we'll all suffer the
consequences of our failure
if we do not come together
to address the urgent threats like covet
19 and climate change
or enduring threats
like nuclear proliferation
the united states remains committed
preventing the right to preventing iran
from granting a nuclear weapon
we are working with the p5 plus one to
engage iran diplomatically
and to seek a return to jcpoa
we're prepared to return to full
compliance
if iran
does the same
similarly
we seek serious and sustained diplomacy
to pursue the complete denuclearization
of the korean peninsula
we see concrete progress
toward an available plan
with tangible commitments that would
increase stability on the peninsula and
in the region
as well as improve the lives of the
people in the democratic people's
republic of korea
must also remain vigilant to the threat
of terror that terrorism poses to all
our nations
whether emanating from distant regions
of the world
or in our own backyard
we know the bitter string of terrorism
the bitter sting of terrorism is real
we've almost all experienced it
last month
we lost 13 american heroes and almost
200 innocent afghan civilians
and a heinous terrorist attack at the
kabul airport
those who commit acts of terrorism
against us will continue to find
a determined enemy in the united states
the world today is not the world of 2001
though
and the united states is not the same
country were when we were attacked on 9
11 20 years ago
today
we're better equipped to detect to
prevent terrorist threats
and we are more resilient in our ability
to repel them
and to respond
we know how to build effective
partnerships to dismantle terrorist
networks
by targeting their financing and support
systems
countering their propaganda
preventing their travel
as well as disrupting
imminent attacks
we'll meet terrorist threats that arise
today and in the future with a full
range of tools available to us
including
working in cooperation with local
partners
so that we need not
be so reliant on large-scale military
deployments
one of the most important ways we can
effectively enhance security reduce
violence
is by seeking to improve the lives of
the people all over the world
who see that their governments are not
serving their needs
corruption
fuels inequality
siphons off a nation's resources
spreads across borders
and generates human suffering
it's nothing less
than a national security threat in the
21st century
around the world we're increasingly
seeing citizens demonstrate their
discontent
seeing the wealthy and well-connected
grow richer and richer
taking payoffs and bribes
operating above the law
while the vast majority of the people
struggle to find a job
or put food on the table
or to get their businesses off the
ground
or simply send their children to school
people have taken to the streets in
every region
to demand that their governments address
people's basic needs
give everyone
a fair shot to succeed
and protect their god-given rights
and in that chorus of voices
across languages and continents
a common cry
a cry for dignity
simple dignity
as leaders it's our duty to answer that
call
not to silence it
the united states is committing to you
committed to using our resources and our
international platform to support these
voices
listen to them
partner with them
to find ways to respond that advance
human dignity
around the world
for example
there's an enormous need for
infrastructure in developing countries
but infrastructure
that is low quality
or that feeds corruption
or exacerbates environmental degradation
may only end up contributing
to greater challenges for countries over
time
done the right way however
with transparent sustainable investment
in projects that respond to the
country's needs
and engage their local workers
to maintain high labor and environmental
standards infrastructure can be a strong
foundation
allows societies in low and middle
income countries to grow
and to prosper
that's the idea
behind the build back better world
and together with the private sector and
our g7 partners
we aim to mobilize hundreds of billions
of dollars in infrastructure investment
we also
will also continue to be the world's
largest contributor to humanitarian
assistance
bringing food water shelter
emergency health care and other vital
life-saving aid
to millions of people in need
when the earthquake strikes the typhoon
rages or disaster anywhere in the world
the united states shows up will be ready
to help
and at a time when nearly one in three
people globally
do not have access to adequate food
adequate food just last year
the united states is committed to
rallying our partners to address
immediate malnutrition
and to ensure
that we can sustainably feed the world
for the decades to come
to that end
the united states is making a 10 billion
dollar commitment to end hunger and
invest in food systems at home
and abroad
since 2000
the united states government has
provided more than 140 billion dollars
to advance health
and strengthen health systems
and we will continue our leadership to
drive these vital investments
to make people's lives better
every single day just give them a little
breathing room
and as we strive to make lives better we
must work
with renewed purpose
then the conflicts that are driving so
much pain and hurt
around the world
must redouble our diplomacy
and commit to political negotiations not
violence
as a tool first resort
to manage tensions around the world
must seek a future
of greater peace and security for all
people of the middle east
the commitment of the united states
israel securities without question
and support our support for an
independent jewish state is unequivocal
but i continue to believe
that a two-state solution
is the best way to ensure israel's
future as a jewish democratic state
living in peace alongside a viable
sovereign and democratic palestinian
state
we're a long way from that goal at this
moment
but we must never allow ourselves to
give up
on the possibility of progress
we cannot give up on solving
raging civil conflicts including in
ethiopia and yemen
we're fighting between warm
warring parties
is driving famine
heroic horrific violence
human rights violations against
civilians including
the constable use of rape
as a weapon of war
we'll continue to work with the
international community
to press for peace
and bring an end to this suffering
as we pursue diplomacy across the board
the united states will champion the
democratic values
that go to the very heart of who you are
as a nation and a people
freedom
equality
opportunity
and a belief in the
universal rights of all people
it stamped into our dna as a nation
and critically it stamped into the dna
of this institution the united states
we sometimes forget
i quote the opening words of the
universal declaration of human rights
quote
the equal and inalienable rights of all
members of the human family
is the foundation of freedom
justice and peace in the world
the founding ethos of the united nations
places the rights of individuals
at the center of our system
and that clarity and vision
must not be ignored
or misinterpreted
the united states will do our part
but will be more successful and more
impactful
if all
of our nations are working toward the
full mission
to which we are called
that's why
more than 100 nations united again
around a shared statement the security
council
adopted a resolution
outlining how we'll support the people
of afghanistan moving forward
laying out the expectations to which
we'll hold the taliban when it comes to
respecting universal human rights
we all must advocate for women
the rights of women and girls
to use their full talents
to contribute economically politically
and socially
and pursue their dreams free of violence
and intimidation
from central america to the middle east
to africa to afghanistan
wherever it appears in the world
we almost call out and condemn
the targeting and oppression of racial
ethnic and religious minorities
when it occurs in whether it occurs in
xinjiang
or northern ethiopia
or anywhere in the world
we all must defend the rights of lgbtqi
individuals
so they can live and love openly without
fear
whether it's chechnya or cameroon or
anywhere
as we steer steer our nations toward
this inflection point
and work to meet today's fast-moving
cross-cutting challenges let me be clear
i am not agnostic
about the future we want for the world
the future will belong to those who
embrace human dignity
not trample it
the future will belong to those who
unleash the potential of their people
not those who stifle it
the future will belong to those who give
their people the ability to breathe free
not those who seek to suffocate their
people with an iron hand
authoritarianism
the authoritarianism of the world
may seek to proclaim the end of the age
of democracy
but they're wrong
the truth is
the democratic world is everywhere
it lives in the anti-corruption
activists
the human rights defenders
the journalists
the peace protesters
on the front lines of this struggle in
belarus burma syria cuba venezuela and
everywhere in between
it lives in the brave women of sudan who
withstood violence and oppression
to push a genocidal dictator from power
and keep working every day to defend
their democratic progress
it lives in the prowl of the moldovans
who helped deliver a landslide victory
for the forces of democracy
with a mandate
to fight graft
to build a more inclusive economy it
lives
in the young people of zambia who
harness the power of their vote for the
first time
turning out in record numbers to
denounce corruption
and chart a new path for their country
and while no democracy is perfect
including the united states
will continue to struggle to live up to
the highest ideals to heal our divisions
and we face down violence and
insurrection
democracy remains the best tool we have
to unleash our full human potential
my fellow leaders
this is a moment where we must prove
ourselves the equals
of those who come before us who with
vision and values
and determine faith in our collective
future built our united nations
broke the cycle of war and destruction
and laid the foundations for more than
seven decades of relative peace
and growing global prosperity now
we must again come together to affirm
the inherent humanity that unites us is
much greater
than any outward divisions or
disagreements
we must choose to do more
than we think we can do alone
so that we'll accomplish what we must
together
ending this pandemic and making sure
we're better prepared for the next one
staving off climactic climate change
and increasing our resilience
to the impacts we already are seeing
ensuring
a future where technologies are a vital
tool to solving human challenges and
empowering human potential not a source
of greater strife and repression
these are the challenges that we will
determine what the world looks like for
our children our grandchildren and what
they'll inherit
we can only meet them by looking to the
future
i stand here today
for the first time in 20 years the
united states not at war
we've turned the page
all the unmatched strength energy and
commitment will and resources of our
nation
are now fully and squarely focused on
what's ahead of us
not
what was behind
i know this
as we look ahead
we will lead we will lead on all the
greatest challenges of our time from
covert to climate
peace and security
human dignity and human rights but we
will not go alone
we will lead together with our allies
and partners and in cooperation with all
those who believe as we do
that this is within our power
to meet these challenges
to build a future
that lifts all of our people
and preserves this planet
but none of this is inevitable
it's a choice
and i can tell you where america stands
we will choose to build a better future
we you and i we have the will and
capacity to make it better
ladies and gentlemen we cannot afford to
waste any more time
let's get to work
let's make our better future now
we can do this
it's within our power and capacity
thank you and god bless you all